- Before all that. I wanna talk about
one of the special things
happening this week.
We asked you to take your
Pilot G2 Gel Ink Pens,
the go to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show
and submit a handwritten
letter about someone
overachieving and bringing the
Christmas Spirit to others.
Um, in other words, a real life Santa.
Uh, today's letter comes from
a mom and her twin daughters.
Let's say hi to Laticia
and her little girls
Luna and Jonella.
(Audience cheering)
We have them on the line right now.
(Audience clapping)
[Kelly] Hi y'all!
- Hi
[Kelly] Okay. So Merry
Christmas to all of you.
First of all, and you look beautiful.
- Thank you! Merry Christmas to you.
- Absolutely. So Laticia
can you read us your letter?
[Laticia] Yes, Dear Kelly.
I want to tell you about
my kids' real life Santa.
We call him Alvin the Elf. Last Christmas,
my four year old twins wrote
letters to Santa and attached
them to balloons.
Alvin found one balloon 600
miles away in Louisiana.
He got the girls everything on the list,
but there was one gift he
couldn't ship. A puppy.
So he actually drove to
us and gave them their
brand new puppy, Max.
If that's not a real life
Santa, I don't know what is.
[Kelly] That's so magical. So
wait we have a picture of Max
right now and also Max
is taking a nap. Oh my...
Oh my God! And that dog,
that dog is so cute!
Oh my gosh. So here's what's cool.
Um, Alvin is also dialed
in, but he has no idea
Laticia and her girls called
him their real life Santa.
(Singing) "Real Life Santa"
[Kelly] We'll hide
Leticia, Luna and Jonella
until we're ready to reveal the surprise.
So, let's bring Alvin in here. All right.
Hi Alvin!
(Audience applause)
Hello!
It's nice to meet you. Can you,
can you tell us about finding the balloon?
- Sure. Uh, last December
I was down in Grand Cane,
Louisiana, deer hunting. And
while I was in the woods,
I came across a Red Mylar
Balloon. So I went to investigate.
And when I got the ballon,
retrieved the balloon,
there was a note attached to it.
So I opened it up and it
was supposed to go to Santa.
So my wife got on the internet
and I asked people to share
it. And we had over 220 shares. And in
- Oh wow!
- less than 24 hours,
we had found the family.
(Audience claps)
[Kelly] Oh my gosh! Um well,
I love what you did for them.
You ended up actually
getting the stuff, right?
- Yeah. My wife then posted an update
that we found the family and
we didn't ask for donations
uh and people, just coworkers, family,
everybody just started donating.
We shipped five boxes of toys,
uh clothes, play clothes,
stuffed animals, blankets, and
all kinds of stuff to them.
But the one thing we could not
ship to them that I talked to
their mom about was a puppy.
We made an arrangement once
he got old enough and we drove
up there and met the family
and it was instant connection.
They love the puppy. They
loved us and we love them.
[Kelly] Aw!
- Now we have an extended
family and I'm an only child.
And she's like my little sister
and we talked and we still
talk and text each way, three
or four times a week or more.
[Kelly] Oh my gosh. Okay. I'm
emotional. Don't say that.
Okay. Woo! Everyday,
what am I talking about?
Well, here's something that
you don't know, uh Laticia
and her girls wrote to me saying
that you are actually their
real life Santa. Um, and they're
on the line and they have
something they want to
say to you. So, Laticia,
kids go for it.
(Audience Applause)
- Hi Alvin!
- Alvin, we want to let you
know that you mean so much
to us. You're such a genuine
person who deserves it all,
you know from the moment that we met you,
we knew that you weren't
just going to be our friend,
but actually part of our
family. We love you Alvin.
Thank you for everything.
[Kelly] Aw!
- I love you so so much, ladies!
[Kelly] So I got to know,
girls how's Max doing?
He looks like he's taking a
pretty good nap right now.
(Audience laughs)
- He is.
[Kelly] Well, Max seems
like the cutest puppy in
all of the land.
So I'm so glad that y'all
got to meet up like this.
It's such a magical story.
Thank y'all for sharing with us.
And you're today's real life Santa, Alvin.
Um, and it comes with
more than just a title.
Pilot G2 Gel Ink Pen is
designed for overachievers,
just like you. And that's
why Pilots using their pen to
write you a check for
$5,000. How's that sound?
(Audience cheering)
- Aw!
[Alvin] Thank you so much! Sorry!
- Alvin said sorry?
[Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- I'm sorry!
- Sorry.
[Kelly] Oh, don't be sorry.
I wish I could hug you
right now. Join me won't you? I'm bawling.
All right. Well thank y'all
so much, Merry Christmas!